Lo que quiero que hagamos en este video es pensar
en lo que significa tener el opuesto de un número,
así que dibujemos una recta numérica y
pongamos algunos números. Empecemos con el 0,
si vamos a la derecha tenemos números positivos:
1, 2, 3, 4, 5; si vamos a la izquierda del 0
tenemos números negativos: -1, - 2, - 3, -4,
y podríamos seguir y seguir y seguir. Ahora,
escojamos un número, escojamos el número
3. ¿Cuál es el opuesto del número 3? Bueno,
el opuesto de un número es otro número que está
a la misma distancia de 0 pero del otro lado,
entonces si 3 está a tres unidades a la derecha
del 0, 1, 2, 3, entonces su opuesto estará tres
unidades pero esta vez a la izquierda del 0:
1, 2, 3, entonces el opuesto de 3 es -3. Bien,
hagamos una pequeña tabla por aquí. Tenemos
el número y su opuesto. Acabamos de encontrar
que si tenemos el número 3 su opuesto será -3.
Ahora, ¿qué pasa si tenemos un número negativo?,
¿cuál es el opuesto del número -4? Te invito a
que pauses el video y lo pienses por tu cuenta.
Bueno, tal vez dijiste -4, está justo aquí, y
está cuatro unidades a la izquierda del 0: 1,
2, 3, 4 a la izquierda de 0, así que su opuesto
estará a cuatro unidades a la derecha de 0:
1, 2, 3, 4, será 4 positivo, + 4. Así que
probablemente empecemos a ver un patrón por aquí:
es lo opuesto de un número será el mismo número
pero con signo contrario. Si tenemos 3 positivo su
opuesto será -3, si empezamos con -4 su opuesto
será + 4. Una forma de verlo es que tendrán el
mismo valor absoluto pero signos contrarios. Otra
forma de pensar en esto es que si tenemos 3 a la
derecha de 0 su opuesto estará 3 a la izquierda de
0; mientras que si tenemos 4 a la izquierda de 0,
entonces su opuesto estará 4 a la derecha de
0. Así que hagamos un último ejemplo. ¿Cuál
es el opuesto de 1? Bueno, 1 está una unidad a
la derecha de 0, su opuesto estará una unidad
a la izquierda de 0, o -1; otra forma de verlo es
que como 1 es positivo, entonces su opuesto tiene
que cambiar de signo: en lugar de ser positivo
será negativo, será -1, como prefieras pensarlo.